[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
[Musique]
pour les patients obèses aller chez le
médecin peut être un enfer presque
systématiquement renvoyé à leur poids
les patients gros sont souvent
culpabilisés
on va s'occuper de la maladie pour
laquelle la personne vient et puis à la
fin dit mais vous savez vous devriez
maigrir conséquence ces patients vont
moins chez le médecin mais se font aussi
mal diagnostiquer
on somme les personnes grosses de se
faire soigner on nous rabâche tous les
jours des choses comme ça mais quand on
veut se faire soigner on peut pas pour
prendre en charge l'obésité des
traitements sont mis en avant comme la
chirurgie bariatrique mais elle n'est
pas toujours la solution miracle le
chirurgien la première fois il m'a dit
clairement bah écoutez monsieur c'est
soit vous soit vous faites l'opération
soit dans six mois on vous enterre alors
comment mieux traiter l'obésité sans
tomber dans la grossophobie médicale
pourquoi est-il urgent de mieux prendre
en charge les patients en surpoids et
obèses trop gros pour être bien soigné
c'est le thème de ce numéro d'état de
santé
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cet
état de santé avec un sujet passionnant
aujourd'hui d'autant qu'on en parle peu
c'est un paradoxe qui frappe les
personnes obèses parce qu'elles sont en
surpoids elles sont fragiles et parce
qu'elles sont en surpoids et bien elles
sont souvent mal soignées vous verrez
c'est assez spectaculaire c'est tout à
fait scandaleux et ça nous concerne tous
on va en parler aujourd'hui avec Gabriel
dédié bonjour à vous bonjour en
arrière-plan on rappelle que 17% de la
population est en obésité la courbe
étant hausse constante Gabriel dédié
vous êtes autrice réalisatrice vous avez
signé aux éditions gouttes d'or on ne
n'est pas grosse qu'on trouve dans les
librairies c'est un livre d'intérêt
public je veux dire que dès les
premières pages où nous prenez par la
main pour nous raconter de façon
saisissante comment on est discriminé et
on va explorer la
grossophobie qu'est-ce que c'est la
grossophobie la grossophobie en fait
c'est le fait de discriminer des
personnes en fonction de leur surpoids
ou de leur ob c'est un mot qui est dans
le dictionnaire il faut le dire oui
c'est reconnu comme tel sa néologisme
qui qui est apparu dans le dictionnaire
il y a pas très longtemps on peut parler
de
grossophobie du quotidien qui pourrait
être les moqueries ou qui pourrait être
le fait de maltraiter une personne on
peut parler de grossophobie médicale et
on peut parler de grossophobie à
l'embauche qui est qui est une vraie
question et dont on parle aussi assez
peu mais nous on va beaucoup parler de
la grossophobie médicale parce qu'elle
existe c'est quand même je disais un
paradoxe c'est vrai que c'est un comble
mais d'abord qui êtes-vous Gabriel dédié
qu'avez-vous fait on regarde votre
portrait
[Musique]
Gabriel dédié est autrice et
documentariste elle fonde le webzin
culturel Ginette le mag en 2014 et
publie en 2017 son premier ouvrage on ne
n'est pas grosse aux éditions de la
Goutte d'Or pour dénoncer la
grossophobie
son livre rencontre un très bon accueil
critique et en 2020 elle l'adapte en
documentaire on achève bien les gros
quelle co-réalise avec Laurent folea et
Valentino Berti basé sur son expérience
et des réflexions sur la grossophobie le
film confronte le spectateur à travers
des petits films qui sensibilisent aux
difficultés quotidiennes des personnes
grosses
le travail de Gabriel dédié n'est pas
cantique
car il amène à réfléchir à la pression
sociale qui pèse sur le corps des femmes
[Musique]
alors Gabriel dédié vous vous êtes tombé
sur des médecins culpabilisants ah mais
complètement
moi je suis tombé sur je parle souvent
de dentiste qui qui m'ont dit qu'ils
avaient peur que je casse le siège c'est
ça le fauteuil
je suis tombée sur un gynécologue qui
m'ont dit que faire une échographie ce
serait gaspiller l'argent de la sécurité
sociale parce que on y verrait pas grand
chose et que ça ne servait à rien j'ai
rencontré des médecins qui pour pour une
otite mon conseiller une chirurgie
bariatrique c'est quand même sidérant
parce que comme vous disiez c'est des
personnes qui doivent vous prendre en
charge vous soigner et d'une certaine
façon elle vous renvoie sans solution à
quelque chose
donc j'imagine ils se disent c'est de
votre faute exactement en fait on est de
quand on est face à un patient obèse en
fait on porte souvent un regard moral
sur cette personne et donc on est plein
de d'a priori et les médecins en les
médecins y compris en fait il y a des
écueils en fait qui consistent à traiter
l'obésité uniquement avec l'alimentation
et des conseils d'hygiène de vie
sportifs etc sauf que c'est enfin c'est
vraiment ne pas connaître l'obésité
d'une part et on se retrouve vraiment
avec avec des conseils parfois qui n'ont
rien de médical qui sont vraiment des
des conseils enfin moraux de vie ou des
changements qu'on porte sur vous
exactement on va le dire Gabriel et
d'ailleurs vous le savez
ce que vous l'avez aussi expérimenté
tous les médecins heureusement tous les
médecins mais on est là aussi pour
montrer ce qui dysfonctionne il y a des
reportages qui valent parfois aussi tous
les discours regarder ce reportage
d'Alexia l'éperon qui précisément aussi
rencontré des témoins et des médecins
regardez
[Musique]
claire souffre de douleurs au ventre
depuis 4 ans
[Musique]
je vous appelle parce que je
souhaiterais avoir un rendez-vous pour
un IRM s'il vous plaît
mais comme à chaque fois ça coince
je suis en très forte obésité et du coup
je voudrais savoir avant me déplacer si
je peux passer dans l'IRM ou pas
je vais bien plus que ça en hauteur
même si certains appareils spécialisés
supportent un poids plus important il
reste un problème la hauteur de son
ventre qui ne passe pas dans la machine
alors sans cet examen clair reste en
errance diagnostique et ne peut pas se
soigner on somme les personnes grosses
de se faire soigner on nous rabâche tous
les jours des choses comme ça mais quand
on veut se faire soigner on peut pas
donc le problème c'est que est-ce que ça
veut dire que ça soit soigner ça veut
simplement dire maigrir en fait mais non
se faire soigner c'est prendre soin de
sa santé dans sa globalité même si je
maigris là demain c'est pas c'est pas
pour ça que j'aurais plus mal et moi
j'ai mal maintenant c'est maintenant
qu'il faut que je me fasse soigner pas
dans quatre ans ou je sais pas quoi
en appelant les services d'imagerie
c'est là qu'on m'a dit Madame si même à
Évry vous rentrez pas
il reste je suis désolé mais il reste la
clinique vétérinaire quoi je me souviens
très bien de cette scène j'ai fondu en
larmes enfin je me suis dit ok je vais
passer entre la vache et le cheval quoi
manque de matériel mais aussi remarque
des médecins clairs et très souvent
confrontés à la grossophobie médicale
alors elle a décidé de s'engager dans
une association
gras politiques l'une de ces actions
l'établissement d'une liste de médecins
bienveillants envers les personnes
grosses sur la base des témoignages des
patients soit il recommande des
praticiens soit au contraire il dénonce
des comportements grossophobes
pendant très longtemps
pouvoir trouver un praticien ou déjà on
sait on va pas anticiper pendant très
longtemps avant d'y aller puis annuler
le rendez-vous parce qu'on a trop peur
là on va là on va y aller on se sentant
mieux et puis quand il y est si tu te
rends compte qu'en effet la personne ça
se passe bien
le soulagement en fait l'une des
médecins jugés bienveillantes dans cette
liste travaille dans ce cabinet parisien
elle a pris l'habitude de répertorier
les remarques assassines entendues par
ses patients
souvent elles viennent de médecins
ton problème c'est la glande pâtissière
je suis désolé pour toi à 20 ans je
mangeais que des cochonneries j'ai vu un
nutritionniste à 27 ans qui m'a dit que
j'avais épuisé mon capital cochonnerait
vous avez perdu du poids depuis
l'hospitalisation parce que c'est le
seul traitement qui marche vraiment il
faut vraiment perdre du poids
effectivement face au passion les
médecins voient le poids d'abord la
santé ensuite
c'est souvent la fin d'une consultation
c'est à dire effectivement on s'occupe
du symptôme qu'on va s'occuper de la
maladie pour laquelle la personne vient
et puis à la fin de mes vous savez vous
devriez maigrir et de façon un peu et
vous savez qu'il faut arrêter de manger
etc alors que parfois ce sont des gens
qui sont en dessous de leur poids
maximum ou alors qui savent très bien je
veux dire les gens qui sont en surpoids
ils savent qu'ils que le poids c'est pas
bon pour la santé sur les patients
obèses cette grosseophobie médicale peut
être plus dévastatrice que l'obésité
elle-même les gens qui sont sur quoi
vont moins consulter donc du coup des
pathologies vont évoluer ne sont pas
être traités à la racine donc ça c'est
embêtant ça c'est du point de vue
somatique après du point de vue
psychologique ça peut être désastreux ça
peut être des astres dans le sens où ça
peut provoquer une crise de boulimie une
crise de panique après
recombrer dans une dépression
selon un sondage doxa un cinquième des
personnes obèses aurait déjà subi des
discriminations dans le domaine
[Musique]
la Gabriel dédié il est quand même assez
spectaculaire ce reportage et ce chiffre
de un patient sur 5 qui concernait par
cette difficulté c'est énorme alors non
seulement c'est énorme mais c'est
sûrement très sous-estimé en réalité
parce que
la particularité du patient obèse c'est
qu'il ne se plaint pas et qu'il a
souvent honte de se plaindre quand il
est maltraité il y a cette idée que
quand on est gros quand on est obèse on
est en mauvaise santé est-ce que c'est
toujours une maladie l'obésité il y a
des débats au sein même des chercheurs
et des et des médecins qui sont
de plus en plus on en a qui nous disent
que si il y a pas de conséquences
métabolique s'il n'y a pas de
comorbidité
lié à l'obésité alors l'obésité on peut
être obèse et ne pas être malade et ne
pas être malade et donc être en bonne
santé oui oui en fait si on n'a pas
développé de comorbidité
a priori on est en bonne santé alors
l'obésité évidemment c'était en surpoids
par définition on va c'est quand même
une maladie un état assez complexe
regardez cette infographie
[Musique]
l'obésité augmente et pourtant certaines
idées reçues persistent jusque dans le
cabinet des médecins
première idée reçue les gros mangent mal
c'est partiellement faux si l'obésité
peut être causée par l'alimentation
d'autres facteurs sont également en
cause il existe notamment une
prédisposition génétique à l'obésité
ainsi 70% de la prise de poids est liée
aux gènes psychologie environnement
horloge biologique ou même le microbiote
intestinal serait aussi responsable
deuxième idée reçue l'IMC suffit à
déterminer si une personne est en
surpoids calculer par une formule simple
le poids divisé par le carré de la
taille l'indice de masse corporelle ou
IMC sert à estimer la masse grasse d'un
individu à plus de 25 il serait en
surpoids et au-dessus de 30 en obésité
mais cet outil standardisé est en fait
réducteur et incomplet il ne prend pas
en compte le degré d'addiposité ainsi de
personnes peuvent avoir un ami MC et
pourtant avoir une masse grasse
différente par exemple l'IMC d'un
sportif peut être élevé car le muscle
pèse plus lourd le gras
troisième idée reçue quand on est gros
il suffit de faire un régime surtout pas
du camp jeunes intermittent cétogène ces
régimes à la mode peuvent faire perdre
du poids drastiquement à court terme
mais à long terme ils sont désastreux et
vont favoriser une reprise de poids plus
importante
en s'habituant à la privation le
métabolisme sera lentille et le corps va
stocker plus de calories pour survivre
au moment où on reprend ses habitudes le
corps s'accroche à ses nouvelles
calories et on grossit ainsi 95% des
régimes sont des échecs plutôt qu'un
régime les nutritionnistes encouragent à
travailler sur le rapport à
l'alimentation et rééquilibrer ses
habitudes alimentaires sur le long terme
l'obésité est un phénomène mal connu
même des médecins et ces idées reçues
peuvent avoir des conséquences graves
sur le soin et la prise en charge des
personnes obèses
[Musique]
le reportage avec cette jeune femme qui
peut pas faire d'IRM et qui dit un
moment j'ai plus qu'à aller à la
clinique vétérinaire je voulais aussi
revenir là-dessus parce que elle dit ça
comme ça c'est une formule c'est une
provocation alors hélas c'est absolument
pas une provocation il se trouve que
beaucoup de patientes dans la situation
de Claire ont dû aller à l'école
vétérinaire pour pour faire des examens
médicaux et ça pose vraiment des
questions qui sont qui sont très
importantes et notamment sur la
déshumanisation de la personne obèse en
fait on culpabilise de de son état de
santé le gros c'est qu'elle enfin c'est
une machine à culpabiliser c'est en
culpabilise quand on peut pas
accompagner des copains au cinéma on
culpabilise au quotidien en culpabilise
quand on nous rejette dans des
entretiens d'embauche on culpabilise
parce qu'on peut pas se faire soigner
forcément vraiment la seule personne
grosse elle va se retrouver en détresse
à un moment donné en fait ça peut
développer des pathologies ça peut
développer des pathologies et en fait le
problème qu'on a à ne pas pouvoir à ne
pas pouvoir diagnostiquer ces personnes
grosses c'est que quand elles auront
quelque chose ça sera forcément quelque
chose de grave et de trop tard il y a
quelque chose d'intéressant je sais que
vous dites je voudrais considérer
quelques instants si vous dites ça
relève aussi un peu du mépris de classe
le regard qu'on porte et les médecins
sur les patients sur les personnes
grosses pourquoi mes prix de classe
statistiquement 33% des personnes au RSA
sont obèses 7% seulement des personnes
qui gagnent 4000 euros et plus le son il
y a un vrai il y a une vraie distinction
sociale on se retrouve avec des
personnes qui qui ne se mélangent pas
qui ne côtoie pas de gros on est
vraiment dans le
le regard moral porté sur sa joue et ça
joue parfois dans la façon dont les
médecins prennent en charge plus ou
moins bien avec plus ou moins de
bienveillance
ces patients alors ce serait un chapitre
en soi mais on va quand même l'ouvrir
avec vous c'est quels sont les solutions
de soins on voulait s'arrêter dans état
de santé sur le fait qu'il y en a une
solution qui revient très souvent pour
faire maigrir entre guillemets c'est la
chirurgie bariatrique bariatrique c'est
un mot qui couvre qui couvre l'estomac
en fait voilà chirurgie de l'estomac
mais ça n'est pas une antitote ou un
miracle absolu parce que ça comporte des
risques regardez ce reportage d'Alexia
le perron
[Musique]
dans cet hôpital la lutte contre
l'obésité passant partie par le bistouri
ce patient s'apprête à être opéré il va
subir une sleeve l'intervention la plus
pratiquée en chirurgie bariatrique là
vous avez l'estomac
on va
introduire un tube de calibration ici et
on sélectionnera à l'estomac le long du
tube de calibration jusqu'en haut et en
fin d'intervention on retire gras cette
partie de l'estomac
si tu peux déplacer ta pince aller vers
la grande courbure
aider par un écran en vision 3D le
chirurgien retire environ 4/5 de
l'estomac
avec un estomac plus petit le patient
opéré atteindra donc plus rapidement la
sensation de satiété il va
automatiquement moins manger
amaigrissement il est brutal et intense
le premier mois après vous avez un
amaigrissement dont la courbe va
diminuer et qui va qui va qui va se
prolonger pendant 12 à 18 mois et après
à partir de deux ans on commence à
parler de poids stables c'est pas une
courbe c'est pas une ligne droite c'est
une courbe qui descend brutalement puis
après ça descend tout doucement le
résultat peut être spectaculaire le
principal résultat attendu étant que cet
amaigrissement se poursuive dans le
temps
en 25 ans le nombre d'opérations de
l'obésité a été multipliée par 20 pour
atteindre environ 600 000 par an
actuellement
pour les patients c'est la promesse
d'une nouvelle vie mais cette promesse
ne tient pas forcément dans le temps
merci pour tout
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que les
deux premières années postes opératoires
on appelle ça la lune de miel des
malades obèses après des années des
années de souffrance il se met d'un seul
coup et brutalement à perdre du poids
ils arrivent à faire pour certains
d'entre eux des activités qui sont
jamais pratiqué il y en a qui retournent
à la piscine en activant des escaliers
il y en a qui courent derrière leurs
petits-enfants et toute cette période là
il s'offre aussi un doigt un droit
l'oubli de leur maladie et
malheureusement au bout d'un certain
nombre d'années il y a une tendance à
oublier qu'on a été opéré à retomber
dans des mauvais travers
il y aurait 25 à 50% de reprise de poids
à long terme
à plusieurs kilomètres d'ici à Caen
c'est ce qui est arrivé à Chris en mai
2019 il se fait opérer d'une sleeve
rapidement la perte de poids arrive
[Musique]
donc là je t'ai déjà moins - 20 - 25
par rapport au tout départ donc j'étais
fier je me disais que ouais ça y est la
nouvelle vie elle a commencé et tout
enfin je rentre dans des vêtements que
je rentrais plus avant mais très vite
affecté par plusieurs décès autour de
lui il relâche ses efforts et reprend du
poids aujourd'hui il fait 10 kg de plus
qu'avant l'opération avec le recul il a
l'impression de ne pas avoir été assez
informé des conséquences
la façon dont le nom d'écrit il y avait
aucun obstacle qui pouvait m'empêcher de
perdre du poids et mettre un petit peu
la pression parce que moi clairement
quand je suis parti voir la chose enfin
le chirurgien la première fois il m'a
dit clairement ben écoutez monsieur
c'est soit vous soit vous faites
l'opération soit dans six mois on vous
enterre donc oui ça on voit clairement
il me l'a dit comme ça quoi donc ouais
bah ça fait réfléchir quoi
désormais Chris s'est lancé un défi
perdre du poids sans chirurgie
bariatrique
par moi-même
c'est juste que je t'ai pas prêt je
pense
alors comment mieux préparer les
patients à cette chirurgie sans la faire
passer pour la solution miracle
[Musique]
retour à Marne-la-Vallée dans le service
de chirurgie de l'obésité
cette médecin voit plusieurs fois les
patients avant leur opération
comment ça va très bien et vous-même
cette passione sera suivie entre 6 à 12
mois avant l'opération mais aussi
longtemps après objectif une
modification durable du mode de vie
pour arrêter les grignotages et ben je
me couche plutôt je me couche à 2h du
matin comme ça j'ai pas la sensation de
faim au tout début il va avoir de toute
manière une alimentation
adaptée mixée et puis surtout il va
démarrer une alimentation fractionnée
que ce soit dans la cible ou le bypass
et cette alimentation fractionnée
normalement elle doit être gardée à vie
la réussite de l'acte chirurgical elle
est conditionnée par le suivi du patient
en préopératoire et aussi post-opérateur
c'est certain ce suivi médical est
nécessaire à vie pour se maintenir dans
son nouveau poids l'opération
bariatrique n'est donc pas une solution
miracle mais plutôt un engagement sur le
long terme il faut en avoir conscience
avant de s'engager dans cette voie
[Musique]
Gabriel dédié ce qui se passe avec le
témoin du reportage d'Alexia c'est qu'en
fait il a lui
la conviction donc c'est son vécu qu'on
l'a forcé à faire cette opération qui a
échoué et pour lui c'est donc un double
échec on lui a proposé quelque chose et
finalement ça marche pas c'est ça la
pression pour se faire opérer elle est
importante vraiment c'est à partir du
moment où vous êtes en obésité dites
massive donc avec un IMC supérieur à 40
vous pouvez être sûr qu'on va vous
parler systématiquement quasiment de
chirurgie bariatrique et la réalité
c'est que c'est c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça notamment au niveau des
suites
le suivi le suivi parce qu'en fait on
parle beaucoup d'échecs en chirurgie
bariatrique en parlant simplement de
poids et donc de reprise de poids et on
peut dire que
en même temps selon l'opération on est
entre 20 et 40% de reprise de poids ce
sont vos dix des opérations maintenant
courantes qui sont intéressantes
financièrement peut-être dans certains
cas pour des cliniques ou des hôpitaux
mais quand même c'est quand même on vous
enlève une partie là on enlève une
partie de l'estomac c'est ça on lui a
enlevé les trois quarts de son estomac
c'est pas anodin quand même c'est pas
toujours et ça marche pas toujours et ça
marche pas toujours parce que on est
encore victime de ces écueils qui sont
juste alimentation et et ils viennent de
vie en général sauf que la réalité c'est
qu'il y a des tas de patients qui ne
sont pas opérables par exemple les
personnes qui se souffrent de troubles
de comportement alimentaire ne doivent
pas être opérés or on sait quand les
opère on a beau vous enlevez un morceau
de l'estomac on continuera parce que ça
relève d'autres choses exactement en
fait on va vous expliquer que vous avez
vous avez toute une équipe musical avec
un psy avec un nutritionniste etc sauf
que le psy et on va le voir une fois ou
deux franchement si vous avez des
troubles du comportement alimentaire
mais que vous voulez vous faire opérer
vous réussissez à vous faire opérer vous
mentez c'est tout donc il y a aussi une
des reports d'addiction ce qui fait
qu'en mange moins mais on se jette sur
autre chose sur l'alcool sur les
médicaments sur les comportements à
risque
la drogue sur le casino sur vraiment il
y a des il y a des personnes qui qui se
mettent en danger d'autres manières on a
aussi un taux de suicide augmenté par
deux chez les personnes qui ont été
opérées par rapport aux personnes obèses
alors on a vu dans le reportage il y a
parfois des suivis qui sont très bien
faits bien sûr les suivis moi ça m'a
frappé à vie donc c'est quand même très
lourd c'est un engagement en plus de
l'opération très fort et le taux de non
suivi et de l'ordre de 80% selon les
établissements donc il faut faire il
faut dire stop ou en tout cas faire en
sorte que l'équipe médicale soit
beaucoup plus vigilante c'est un peu une
usine il y a une espèce d'industrie à
l'opération bariatrique c'est ce qu'on
comprend de ce que vous dites
complètement
sociale ce sont des opérations
qu'aujourd'hui en fait en ambulatoire
enfin vous repartez le soir si tout va
bien il y a enfin
en réalité enfin ces opérations
aujourd'hui on estime que 2,8% de la
population a été opérée on sensibilise à
toutes ces problématiques est-ce que
vous voudrez que ça bouge ou pas du tout
ça dépend enfin moi je trouve que alors
je trouve que ça prend très bien au
niveau des débats je trouve qu'on en
discute de plus en plus
par contre au niveau des pouvoirs
publics moi je vois pas je vois aucun
aucun changement en fait et je veux dire
une chose qui est très importante c'est
que
on peut très bien parler de grossophobie
et lutter contre l'obésité c'est pas du
tout antinomique en fait c'est pas parce
que on va prendre en charge les
personnes grosses qu'on va parler des
discriminations des personnes grosses
qu'on va encourager les gens à rester
gros c'est pas du tout c'est pas du tout
l'idée l'idée c'est que il y a des
personnes grosses qui existent il y en a
qui maigriront il y en a qui maigriront
jamais et que faisons-nous de ces
personnes là en fait donc
c'est juste traiter le citoyen enfin les
gros sont des citoyens comme les autres
et donc on doit les traiter de la même
façon on en est pas grosse aux éditions
de la Goutte d'Or Gabriel dédiée je
recommande votre livre merci encore une
fois formidable merci de votre
témoignage Gabriel et on se retrouve
très vite pour un prochain numéro d'état
de santé
[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec mgeen mutuelle santé prévoyance
vous a présenté état de santé
[Musique]